Emily Best (Seed & Spark): The word ‘crowd-funding’
is a compound word.
There are two words in that word and the first
word is not there because it is a prettier
word.
It’s there because it’s a more important
Richard Botto (Stage 32): I just can’t stress
it enough that especially when it comes to
crowdfunding, it all comes down to relationships
and it all comes down to building those relationships
and keeping those relationships.
Sheri Candler (Author): I’m not saying you
need millions of people but you need a core
group of people because those are the ones
who are going to help you spread the word.
You’re not going to be able to spread via
word of mouth all by yourself.
Brian Jun (Filmmaker): We’re all encouraged
in our life that we can do whatever we want,
that we are entitled to achieve our dreams
and we can do “this” and we can do “that.”
And with crowdfunding people think that “Oh,
well now that’s the answer to my question.
I just put my project up there and since I’m
entitled to have a dream, I’m entitled to
write a book or make a movie or be a ballet
dancer or put on my theatre production.
That people now are going to give me money.”
Spike Lee (Filmmaker): We shot SHE’S GOTTA
HAVE IT in 1985.
We were doing Kickstarter before there was
Kickstarter!
We just didn’t have the technology.
Alexis Kirke (Professor): Generating a fan
base.
Ah, now that’s the question.
I’ve never solved the generating a fan-base
question.
Ryan Koo (NoFilmSchool.com): I never would
have launched a campaign for 6 figures if
I hadn’t spent two years building an online
audience with a website.
Jon Reiss (Author and Instructor): The way
you structure your campaign will largely determine
whether you are successful or not.
Alexis Kirke: I certainly know I’ve been
on the other side of the crowdfunding thing.
It’s been quite tempting to think “Wow,
I could be part of this movie!” and the
guy is not famous or anything but maybe it
will be a successful movie and I’ll have
been part of it.
Hunter Weeks (Filmmaker): I try my hardest
to try to stay connected online wherever with
people who are really reaching out to me.
I don’t see why we shouldn’t be.
Etta Devine and Gabriel Diani (Filmmakers
and Actors): It’s really surprising that
no one gets back to you…so…I don’t know
what that is?
Mike Hedge (Filmmaker): It’s a race.
Your crowdfunding is like a real amazing time
where it’s just like you can’t think about
anything other than getting the word out and
making an update video.
And posting new things and getting people
interested in trying to get film blogs to
talk about it.
Merete Mueller and Christopher Smith (Filmmakers):
I think one of the really lucky things about
our project is that we had the tiny house
community there ready to kind of help us get
the word out.
Chad Diez and Art Hall (Filmmakers and Actors):
Not having a good pitch video (to me) I feel
like is…the ones I’ve seen I’m like
“I would never donate to that because the
video wasn’t good.”
Whether it was production value or just the
pitch wasn’t good.
I just didn’t feel like it was a compelling
enough story.
Marc Zicree (Author and Filmmaker): I put
a couple months in on the video and part of
it…one thing I recognized with Kickstarter
that was very, very clear is that you have
to have a personal touch.
Joke and Biagio (TV Producers): I would not
have had a successful Kickstarter, we would
not have had a successful Kickstarter campaign
if we weren’t truly, 100% passionate about
the film.
Patrick Shen (Filmmaker): We researched a
lot of campaigns.
We probably looked at about a 100 different
campaigns.
We watched all the videos, we looked at the
rewards, the perk structure, all the text
on the actual Kickstarter page.
Angel Valerio and Christopher Miles (Filmmakers
and Actors): Sometimes you get discouraged.
“Wow, I just sent like 1,000 emails and
it’s still not moving!” and then “Oh,
yeah!
Somebody pledged.”
I’m like “Okay, we’re good.
Let’s keep going.
Let’s keep going.”
Nicolas Alcala (Filmmaker and Speaker): I
think for short films and books and albums
and any other things, that if it’s [the
campaign asking amount] below $30,000, it’s
great.
Over that [amount], you’re going to have
a hard time.
You might be lucky.
But one out of a thousand is going to be successful
and the rest is going to fail.
Andy Viner (Filmmaker): It does get people
involved and creates an audience that wants
to see your movie and that’s invaluable
but there’s…I guess what I would say is
that none of these things come without…you
don’t gain something without giving something
up.
Miguel Duran and Violeta Reina Duran (Filmmakers):
That’s one of those cases where our entire
momentum went back to zero and it was very
hard not just to start up from that point
but to start off from a really, really low
point.
Judy Chaikin (Filmmaker): Well I think any
pursuit that you do in life is filled with
failures and successes and you often learn
more from your failures than your success,
so of course you have to pick yourself up,
what else?
Are you going to lie in the dirt the rest
of your life?
It’s not an option!